and then me getting together with Bobby
like reinvigorated a part of our careers
that wasn't there before and then people
see it and they're like whoa what the
[__]
these guys are you know
you guys have a solid fan base huge yeah
it's wonderful I do I'm so appreciative
of what we created together we created a
little nugget of psychopaths that love
to watch us fight we we really truly
made that because
I said it before that show was birthed
from his relapse when his dad died and
he relapsed he pulled me aside in the
hallway at his old condo
and I knew something was wrong
and he was like told then he told me
that he was high
and I knew I knew something was weird
and he was like if you tell anybody I
will never talk again
and so immediately I went home and I
panicked told everybody yeah what am I
going to do I was like I have to start
telling people I can't I can't hide this
this is nuts
but I didn't tell kalila and at the time
they were together
and uh you know she had reached out to
me far after the fact that this all went
away
and was like I'm really sorry he put you
in that predicament I understand why you
didn't come to me because it was like
what am I gonna
get in the middle of their relationship
like it was it was really a vulnerable
position for me to be in so I made it my
own way to get him to try to get help
without having to bring it to the
relationship part because it was really
hard man yeah how long ago was that
because we talked about it on the last
time he was on the podcast like my
brother was on tour with him and he
ratted them out yeah and uh he still
hasn't talked to my brother since then
yeah well he's a vindictive [__] I
mean he's a [__] [__] but but
also you know sobriety and addiction
makes you do [__] really strange
things to people that you love so I
think he's always going through it but
that was in 20
well and I knew when his dad died he was
avoiding the idea that his dad was dead
it was like he faked it he like showed
up
he he it's like he didn't care and I was
like this is fake it's you care so
you're dealing with it in a way that you
don't want to communicate and obviously
it was using behind everybody's back so
once that came to
that came to the surface
I knew everything was going to kind of
collapse so he went away to rehab and
then when we went to Mexico where I saw
you guys he relapsed again and then
that was that was
that was kind of like a um a window into
the world of what it's like to like have
one of your best friends really really
struggle with addiction because I you
know of that addicts in my life my dad
really good friends but I didn't never
seen it like I did with Bobby where
he'll he'll he'll he'll put you in a
really vulnerable position like really
vulnerable dude it was crazy threatened
you know he threatens you and does all
this [__] manipulative [__] to
make you be like yeah well they're out
of their [__] mind but like you don't
really believe it because you're like
dude it's Bobby but like he's really
just no different than any other [__]
psycho alcoholic that's like saying some
weird [__] yeah he just didn't he just
never he you know but now he's got such
a good grasp that I'm like happy for him
that he's functioning again
clear-headed and he's found a new level
from this second term of sobriety but
the show was birthed truly because we
joked about doing a show I filled in for
him when he was having some trouble me
and kalila would do tigerbelly together
and then
we had joked about doing the show and
then when he relapsed he pulled me aside
when kalila called him out and they sent
him away to rehab and he's like I had a
realization that like we we should
become
closer instead of this Fringe thing that
we're doing and actually do the show
together and commit and you know and you
guys don't have guests on you guys
basically sometimes we have guests on
that we know are fun for the show yeah
we usually don't want people on the show
but like Steve and there's guys that
like we know are
fun as [__] that are going to be fun
with us on the show yeah you know so
like like the fact that you can do it
without a guest is so important yeah
it's because it's Dynamic is me and that
[__] weirdo is really what it is I
mean we throw in fun people because we
like those personalities that we just
know that are great with us yeah like
Brad Williams he rips every time he's on
the show absolutely [__] rips we put
him in an elf costume for the Christmas
episode it's one of the funniest
episodes we've ever done and there's a
joke that went viral because uh Rudy on
the show the girl on the show his niece
or Colada's niece was like is there a
dating app for little people and we all
start laughing and Brad's like that's a
good question like it is a good question
and I said what's the name of it and and
I was like wait a minute let us guess
let us have a comedy guest of this and
dude Bobby the fastest I've ever seen
him he goes a thumbel and I I [__]
lost my [__]
there's moments like that that you're
like yeah when the dynamic is firing
it's flawless I mean when it's when it's
fun with me and that idiot it's [__]
fun it's the most fun I've ever had it's
more fun than in a TV show I've shot any
movie I've done any stand-ups that I've
ever done when that kid and I are
humming it's the most fun I've ever had
in my entire life
part of the other suggestions for for
the for the little person the lp LP
dating site oh we threw out a million of
them they're on the episode watch the
Christmas episode but I can't we went
for like five minutes making each other
laugh on on [__] but it was just I
don't know like those yeah dude when
we're humming on that show I genuinely
mean it from the bottom of my heart I've
never had more fun as an adult making
comedy it reminds me of when I was 22
and I started and we would talk [__]
after bombing at open mics and we'd all
be in the parking lot making fun of each
other for how bad we bombed it it's the
same thing it felt the same way it was
like innocent and raw and stupid it was
so dumb it's when me and that kid are
talking [__] it's so dumb it's the
dumbest thing on earth it's great how is
that whiskey Ginger compared to
tigerbelly
we're performance we're talking or bad
friends you mean oh yes right yeah yeah
yeah oh bad friends is huge dude we do a
million downloads a week we're huge that
one's way bigger my shows my Show's like
400 Grand or something like that it's
half of it you know
um do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butt hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude